so I've got the website open and I
opened up devtools to the network tab
I've hit refresh and all of the network
requests are shown here's one image and
here's the other notice that their size
definitely isn't the same one is 123
kilobytes while the other is only 63
kilobytes it looks like Udacity large
has different dimensions than Udacity
small dollar sign zero refers to
whatever element you have selected up in
the elements pane which in this case is
the image when you do dot natural width
on the image you see that its original
with a 601 pixels now we want to take a
look at the other image running the same
command gives us 12 02 pixels so large
is twice as big as small the thing is
though that both of these images look
well pretty much identical so there's a
lot of wasted bites when you deliver an
image with dimensions that are just too
large well yes some high DPI displays do
need images that have larger dimensions
than what's displayed that's going to be
a topic later on in this course for now
just remember that images only need to
be as large as they will be displayed
and what happens to your users on mobile
in devtools I've set network throttling
2 3g so I want to see what it's like for
somebody on a bad connection let's
refresh and watch ooh notice how the
image on the right took a little bit
longer to show up that's just
unnecessary on a mobile device with
limited connectivity it's a big problem